look at this fashion thank you this is  American Music Award yep in here a big  night for you tonight with Kesha tell me  all about it I'm super excited to be  here with my girl Kesha we came to raise  hell tonight yes we came great she  brushes her teeth with a bottle of Jack  that's a lot that is a lot tell me about  your musical journey to get here what  does it mean to be here it's just you  know is inspiring you know to be here  and to just be on my journey for so long  and to continue to represent from New  Orleans and tell me about the fashion is  there a secret to this look it's  libertine so if you know a little  Liberty fashion move a little circle yes  show us full yes yes yes  [Applause]  [Music]